I just had to turn the crane back on for
this which is the wet zone how'd they
know that I was going to show up
it's working good framing is actually
yeah really
Oh shocking um we're walking to the zoo
is that important to say and we're gonna
find out about this much about this as I
did
yeah probably most of online walk just
turn out to be jokes yeah and I look
really stupid channeling Casey nice dad
right now with the gorilla tripod and
holding it out in front of me and
looking like an idiot talking to myself
yes so not that he's an idiot I'm not
trying to insult him in any way I'm just
saying when I do it I look stupid time
for the time lapse yeah what is that
okay blog leader vlog later please
vlog my leader your antics are
definitely gonna get me more views but
later my four foot nine arms are very
small my arms themselves aren't four
foot nine I'm saying I'm four foot nine
and my arms are proportional to that
height
a brother fist top of the morning to you
laddies that's those are the same person
wait you're saying PewDiePie
jacksepticeye are the same person
oh Jesus he's become a battle top of the
crystal there's the thumbnail right
there right there he pi jacksepticeye
are the same person
put them blocks face in the thumbnail I
want to film the evolution of mark
figuring out the shots gonna be yeah I'm
gonna goodbye people will know just by
my emotions I don't know I don't want to
breathe it
all right you think I can pull
are you take their side yeah okay ready
all right
all right he just wants us all the watch
watches he murders his other her shell
the other turtles like I approve oh my
god he stepped on his head oh no I feel
that we were joking but I think this is
really happening
oh oh free him free him so I just
dropped my mic um this is more of a test
to see if it's still working yeah yeah
probably hey alright so we're leaving
the zoo and we're gonna go elsewhere cuz
we're in DC and yeah we're gonna look at
people and mostly people have just been
looking at me oddly enough I don't know
why it's doing a lot of this I'm tasting
nice tat
[ __ ]
you
well now you're just super backward that
good enough for me it's all I need I
don't need to be lit I'm already lit
enough as it is I'm clever enough to
dance on you on the fly is that a good
clean sound I can have that airplane
good little bit that's nice
okay so Bob push push push
Bob just told me that it's magic our
mark sorry
Bob just told me that a tree bob just
told me that it's magic hour right now
and this is when lighting looks the best
so I just turned on my camera so that
people could know this fact I'm not
doing that what did you do I mean he
didn't do anything shut up
I wasn't talking then shut up good okay
these are my friends all right we've
been walking quite a while we're all
starting to get tired and sweaty and
gross there's a lot of fluids building
up all over the place um and eventually
we'll get back home just not yet
that's what Mark thinks am I never going
home actually that thing I said early
about you already being dead that's true
oh nice cool well I'm dead so sorry guys
I'll soon don't worry okay
as always I'll see you in the next life
Bubba that's how you go out my last
words bye bye this is good thumbs up
let's go home and now get some food and
then
not not worried about being all sweaty
we get the same shot here I'll film your
screen call you covered come on walk
that same shot nice yeah nice I'm gonna
get copyright claim yeah yeah yeah okay
so I didn't like the last goodbye so I'm
gonna do another goodbye um dick dick
dick dick dick dick dick dick dick dick
dick dick dick dick dick okay bye